yes hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 198 no chance
it's Prime we are back after uh a long
Hiatus that we um had no choice but to
have because we were uh in motion across
the globe and visiting various places
which we will talk about during today's
live stream yeah we're going to uh we're
going to spend some time I've written
about it few times now on Natural
Selections but spend some time talking
about our time in Prague and then London
and then my time in Denver uh from which
I just returned yesterday and you got
back from London a few days ago uh so
that's going to be what we do today
we're also going to have a live Q&A
after this on Rumble only please join us
on Rumble if you're watching this live
even if you're not and join us on locals
where there's a watch party going on
right
now and uh the Q&A you can ask questions
at Darkhorse missions.com we're going to
talk about various other things like our
cool merchandise and Jake's micro pizza
oh man is that stuff good it is tasty
new flavors too do you say flavors and
pizza flavors um um styles styles themes
themes new new themes
of yeah no it's um it's selling like hot
cakes I mean you just uh you can't get
enough I mean Pizza is a kind of a hot
cake isn't it I guess technically but um
but uh but you can't get enough that's
my feeling about it having uh um been
delighting a good deal of Jake's micro
Pizza over our travels yes indeed yeah
available now at Darkhorse store.org
okay uh we're g to jump right into the
ads we as always are very grateful for
our sponsors we start up with three ads
at the top of the hour and then none uh
throughout the rest of our time with you
and uh without further Ado let's do that
and I think you are first wow yeah
that's new okay I'm on it you
ready uh our first sponsor is Vivo
barefoot um and in fact they were our
very first sponsor for the podcast and
they were not one of our one of our okay
so friends bear with me um I'm having a
little dyslexia flare up which often
happens um pretty much anytime I read
things but they were early though they
they were one of our first sponsor they
were and they remain one of our
favorites because awesome shoes which it
doesn't even say on the paper so
dyslexia uninvolved but Vivo Barefoot
makes shoes for feet everyone should try
them most shoes are made for someone's
idea of feet but Vios are made for
people who made by people who actually
know feet uh and word is spreading
people have approached us because of the
vios that we are wearing saying that
they've heard they're good and they want
to know if they are well yes indeed
these shoes are Beyond comfortable the
tactile feedback from the surfaces you
are walking on is amazing they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they are fantastic
your feet my feet are fantastic I have
heard really I mean I'm not really one
of those people who's overly focused on
feet but yes I've heard they are
spectacular from you actually and I know
you were kidding so anyway no not really
they're pretty good I I mean I really
don't care about feet either except so
far as they're functional all yeah um
yeah they they I they have gotten me
this far let's put it that
way where was I ah yes I was going to uh
describes some of the uh the background
of uh Vivo Barefoot see our feet are the
product of millions of years of
evolution humans have evolved to walk
move actually they're the result of
billions of years of evolution but uh in
foot form it's really millions that
they've had a chance to be uh modified
to the
purpose true I think longtime listeners
will be pleased to know that um yes
modern shoes that are overly cushioned
and strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a Health crisis people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural natural strength from the ground
up foot strength increases by 60% in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them Vivo Barefoot has a great range
of Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking and to
training and everyday wear you're also a
certified B Corp that is pioneering
generative bus business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild upon
it Vivo barefoot shoes are always sold
in pairs go to Vivo barefoot.com and use
the code Darkhorse 15 to get an
exclusive offer 15% off additionally new
customers get 100 day free 100 day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's vi v b a r e e f o
t.com and use the code Darkhorse 15 at
checkout nice not all of that was on the
page but yeah you sort of slid past one
of the really important things here
which is that um they are always sold in
pairs unlike some shoe retailers who
will remain nameless here you do not
place an order and get excited for when
it comes and find only one shoe in the
Box no you will always get two always
get to actually did you know that my
great great grand Uncle invented the
idea of selling shoes by the pair and
ironically died penniless with one shoe
terrible terrible story it is a tragic
yeah it was it was bad but um you rest
in
peace okay second
ad our second sponsor this week is
American Harford gold if you've been
listening to our course for any length
of time then you're already tuned in to
just how incompetent and unstable many
of our institutions are becoming and
it's getting worse daily interest rates
are skyh high we are CAU between runaway
inflation and a recession while being
assured that all is fine the cost of
food housing Medical Care schools
everything is climbing while the quality
declines our leaders are increasingly
nonsensical all of this threatens
businesses jobs and retirement funds
finding ways to secure your nest egg and
insulate your wealth is more important
than ever and adding precious metals to
your assets is a great way to stabilize
your Investments and protect yourself
financially American Hartford gold is a
precious metals dealer that can help you
do just that American Hartford gold
helps individuals and families protect
their wealth by divers ifying with
precious metals they make it simple and
easy to protect your savings and
retirement accounts with physical gold
and silver with one short phone call
they can have physical gold and silver
delivered right to your door or inside
your IRA or 401K they are the highest
rated firm in the country with an A+
rating from the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of satisfied clients if
you call them right now they will give
you up to $5,000 of free silver on your
first qualifying order contact them
today by visiting the link in the
episode description below or call 866
82811109
that's 866 828-1114 or text Darkhorse to
98899 once more the phone number is 866
82811109
8899 all right and our final sponsor
this week is ancient it's armura armor
is
colostrum armor itself is not so ancient
but colostrum is colostrum is the first
food that every mammal eats produced in
the first two or three days of an
infant's life and is nutritionally
different from the milk that comes in
afterwards mammals have existed for 300
million years give or take a few tens of
millions and the first food every mammal
has eaten is colostrum colostrum serves
many vital functions including that of
protecting and strengthening
strengthening the mucosal barriers of
infants before their own barriers mature
modern living breaks down your mucosal
and immune barriers and Arma is the
superfood that builds it back armor
colostrum protects and strengthens your
body's barriers creating a seal that
guards against inflammation at everyday
toxin pollutants and threats armor uses
their cold chain biop potent technology
to concentrate colostrum 400 plus living
nutrients into their most pure and
bioavailable form according to review
published in the journal clinical
nutrition open science in 2022 bovine
colostrum has been used to treat cancer
AIDS polio heart disease and rheumatoid
arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and its use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve athletic performance and
recovery time support healthy digestion
and produce allergy symptoms armor
starts with sustainably Source colostrum
from grass-fed cows from their Co-op of
dairy farms in the USA they Source only
the Surplus colostrum after calvs are
fully fed unlike most colostrums which
use heat pasteurization that depletes
nutrient potency armor uses their cold
chain biopot Tech an Innovative process
that purifies and preserves the
Integrity of hundreds of bioactive
nutrients while remov in cassin and fat
to guarantee the highest potency and
bioavailability of any colostrum
available on the market the quality
control is far above industry standards
including being certified to be
glyphosate fate free
Hallelujah benefits of Armor's colostrum
also include clearing of blemishes
Shiner Shiner no shinier let's go with
Shiner thicker hair that's not as
attractive as it no no no no does not
wrong with the tongue benefits of armor
colostrum does not include shinier
Shiner thicker hair but rather shinier
and thicker hair clearing of blemishes
stabilization of blood sugar levels and
acceleration of fat burning and
colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decrease recovery time
after intense exercise armor has a
special offer for the Darkhorse audience
receive 15% off your first order go to
tr ara.com Darkhorse or enter Darkhorse
to get 15% off your first order that's
TR r
ym
a.com Dark
Horse done we are there we are
there so so so well I mean I I I would I
would like to start by pointing
something out you and I are obviously VI
ly in a slightly giddy mood which is
something that happens now and again and
we are in a slightly giddy mood at a
moment where the outside world is full
of no shortage of uh dire Revelations
and I would just point out something
I've I've noticed in a different context
um which is you know if you go to a
funeral it does not look like what you
would imagine there are moments that
look like what you would imagine and
there are moments in which people are
laughing and talking about things that
are not exactly related to the the loss
that people have suffered humans are a
very interesting creature and the
ability to laugh in dire times is a uh a
very important tool because of course
laughter is tied to some deep circuitry
that is not especially well understood
evolutionarily it's been something I've
spent a lot of time thinking about and
uh let's just say our understanding of
it is not is not perfect um but in any
case we bring the tools to bear that are
useful and the idea that you know you
would imagine that you know a world at
war we are not globally at War at least
not yet but a world at war would not be
a world in which um were people were
laughing you know if we think back on
the depression we see it in sepia tone
if we think back on the Holocaust in
World War II we don't think of uh people
experiencing anything other than the
constant horror of um that chapter of
History but of course that's not the way
it is um you reminded me of a wonderful
film that made this point um while we
were in Prague yeah yeah called uh life
is beautiful life is beautiful and I
forgotten the name of the Italian actor
who did such a brilliant job in it um
but in that film uh it's it's a
fictional uh story but uh a father in a
concentration camp um takes great risk
and goes way out of his way to provide
as much normaly for his his son as he
possibly can including a great deal of
humor um it's uh Robert Roberto banini
benini right who also directed it oh I
had forgotten that anyway um so uh I
don't think we should uh make any
apology or be at all embarrassed about
um the fact that all of the features of
Life continue through all of the
chapters of history and that's simply
the nature of Being Human I I would say
um in fact it's it's even better than
that whoa I know um no I think we need
to I think we absolutely need to and in
fact the um the piece that I posted on
Natural Selections yesterday uh makes
this point in in two domains but I think
it applies um to to humor to sport to a
number of things outside of what I talk
about which is music and dogs uh which
is to say that um maybe especially but
certainly during a time of you know Mass
upheaval and dissonance uh both
cognitive and otherwise uh what are the
things that will actually bring us
together remind us of our shared
humanity and um and you know the the the
shared faith that we have by virtue of
being on a single gorgeous Planet
together and having nowhere else to go
uh let us let us refind our connection
and um music certainly helps us do that
and um maybe we'll talk a little bit but
I you know I wrote about this experience
we had in this Pub in Prague um and and
dogs bring us together as as well uh and
you know I've been watching since really
I mean forever but I specifically
started noticing uh as the lockdowns
began to ease a little bit and then of
course they came back on the west coast
of the United States over and over and
over again but maybe Midsummer 2020 when
people were finally coming out of their
homes again you I've been walking in
these Parks I'm seeing no one for a
while and you know people finally
started coming out and people were still
mostly had been convinced to be scared
of one another that humans are the enemy
other humans are the things that will um
you know give infect you and and and you
know kill you or your loved one as a
result um but people with dogs were able
to make connections because dogs dogs
don't care right um and dogs despite
everything that we are doing are on our
team and if we let them uh make the
connections for us even if we are too
scared or uncomfortable or anxiety
ridden or whatever to to do it uh then
we might actually find new connection
with people yeah I uh of course agree
with this point and I would also point
out that there's an online version of
this which of course anything online is
a um
a what is it a lower dimensionality
reflection of the same same principle
but the way you know if you look uh at
the way people react to it's not just
dogs but dogs especially animals um you
know where somebody will post a video
that will reveal that an animal has some
kind of cognition that you wouldn't NE
necessarily expect you know there's I
saw one the other day of a a dog um
dragging its own sled up a hill and then
sledding down and then taking the sled
back up the hill and anyway the way in
which all of the usual things that cause
us to detest each other do not show up
in those discussions right you could
have you know uh White supremacists and
Jews or blacks in the very same
conversation having the very same
reaction to the very same animal because
what it does is it it brings out the
humanity uh in people and um well and
and so does music so does shared music
so maybe this is um I I wrote about it
and you haven't seen what I wrote about
it um but I'm I'm curious to hear um
without us having discussed it uh how
you remember experience uh in the pub in
Prague after the uh the book baptism so
uh we were we're in Prague for the
launch of our book in Czech um in the
Czech Republic a a book launch is called
a book baptism and they literally pour
some champagne over the book and um The
Institute ag21 a fabulous organization
uh published our book and invited us to
come out there and we met both the uh
the founder and philanthropist U Behind
The Institute and spent a lot of time
with the director and several of the
research Associates there and you know
to a person they are extraordinary uh
and uh and after and and we spent we we
we did several we did several podcasts
while we were there and and some
interviews and also spent some
considerable social time with Adam the
director um and um and and Carol the uh
founder and um Susa and Eva and many
other people there uh and they were it
was all wonderful but a particular night
after the book baptis baptism in which
um several people who had shown up for
the launch um cze people um who either
knew us from before before or who who
had heard about this book and came to
the launch um went to this Pub so I I'm
I'm now curious you want me to describe
it well yeah I've just written about it
so it'll be interesting to see how our
how our Reflections um converge what you
focus on and if there's any points of
disagreement sure I'd be happy to off
the top of my head yeah um anyway the
the uh there's a lot to say about Prague
and so just we will come back to this
and in fact
um almost everywhere we went we walked a
lot not even just in the historic
district but out of the historic
district into the parks that the the
Czech people uh frequent and and all of
this and almost everywhere we walked was
cobbled almost the entire way um not
just the roads but the sidewalks and not
all of it was old cobbling a lot of it
was new and actually this raises some
interesting points so looked to me like
that's expensive um and I talked to some
some check do we call them
checks some check folks I know I can get
yeah check people um yeah I don't know
how we we deal with citizens of the
Republic in in plural but in any case I
talked to some of them and their point
was no actually it's cheaper because you
can get to the stuff underneath it and
then repair a little piece so anyway
it's like carpet tiles but far classier
far classier but also I don't know what
damage we are going to discover we are
doing to ourselves by walking on
extremely flat extremely hard surfaces
like concrete everywhere but just the
amount of normal feedback that removes
from you uh is substantial and the
cobbling the slight wobbles and raised
bits and all of that makes walking a
much more lively experience but imagine
see earlier Point around Vivo Barefoot
actually exactly I was thinking exactly
that but anyway we came in uh at night
after the baptism which I when I first
read that there was going to be a
baptism I assumed that somehow you
because of the uh champagne was
mentioned and baptism and champagne
don't go together as far as I know so I
assumed that it was going to be a
christening in which somehow a bottle
was broken but oh nope nothing like that
anyway we went to the pub down the uh
Cobble Street uh the ceilings and Prague
are very often not like the ceilings um
here in the US they are not flat they
are domed with interesting edges we sat
down at a big wood table uh noisy and
boisterous and all and Adam um being the
uh unusual creature that he is had
brought his guitar with him thinking
that he would play uh some Czech songs
what you were going to he specifically
wanted us to do campfire together and
and it it had started to rain during the
baptism so he couldn't um so he couldn't
go outside and have have campfire but he
still had his guitar with him still had
his guitar with him and I should say um
there is something very interesting to
be said about the fact that the Czech
language is only spoken by the people of
this one country and so about 10 million
strong yeah so it's not a huge language
group and it's not an easy language
either it does mean that all of the
young people seem to speak English which
was made life easy for us um because
Czech isn't useful so they're all
bilingual which makes for an interesting
culture um but anyway uh he had brought
his guitar and he'd been talking to us
about uh some prominent Czech singers
actually singers who are widely known
but have become controversial as a
result of having been steadfast about
certain principles having acknowledged
Nuance were I don't know interesting
stuff so anyway during during pre 1989
during the time that Prague that the
Czech Republic was still Czechoslovakia
and behind the Iron Curtain right and so
I think the story if I remember
correctly about one of these people was
that um his name had showed up on a list
of collaborators with the Soviets which
did not necessarily mean that he had
actually done anything because what it
apparently took to end up on one of
these lists um was effectively nothing
but nonetheless after uh the the Iron
Curtain fell and then the Czech Republic
became independent of uh the slovaks um
this was viewed dimly so even though the
songs are universally known by people
who still sing them there's some deeper
story y but anyway um we're sitting
around this big table with these people
some of whom we uh have known um
reasonably well over the course of a
week had a lot of conversations some of
them are new to us and Adam breaks out
his guitar and he starts playing these
Czech songs which are fascinating but of
course we have no idea what's being said
but it was interesting people at the
next table over uh started joining in
and they were singing along with Adam's
playing and Adam's playing became very
uh vigorous because of course now there
was this great sense of community in the
pub and then a part of the story which I
still still cannot quite reconcile
suddenly four other instruments came out
of nowhere somebody was playing a um a
um accordion there was an accordion
there was a violin I think and I'm
missing an instrument somewhere that's
all I remember I remember the violin
first and then the accordion and there
were three instruments and all the
voices except for ours all the voices
everybody who spoke check in the room
was singing these songs and um so I
should say I've forgotten one piece of
the puzzle which is that we will get
back to what the meaning of all of this
is but the Czech people because of their
long history and maybe especially
because of their
um resentment of the Soviets uh During
the period of of uh the Soviet hegemony
over over
Czechoslovakia um
are um nobly subversive by Nature right
these people they're not these are not
anarchists these are people who um
defied Soviet rule in many little ways
um right under the nose of the people
who uh were were oppressing them and
this is just sort of built into their
character and actually um the analogy of
the Shire was um actually invoked by
several people um that there is kind of
a you know these sort of independent
idiosyncratic folks um uh some of whom
are up for uh heroic Adventure um but
anyway so the uh the pub is um
uproariously singing These famous Czech
songs and um the
barkeep had apparently had a complaint
or was in fear of a complaint and he
walked over um slightly sheepishly to
Adam who was playing his guitar and told
him to keep it down down and at the
point that he finished his sentence uh
Adam reached the chorus and bursted
directly into his face and then instead
of being angry at this or something he
kind of rolled his eyes like yeah if I
wasn't working I'd be on your side
singing as loudly as you are and so
anyway it was a a beautiful little uh
vignette of the subversion of the this
you know very small culture um in which
you know know people had their
instruments and and we were told this
was not a common phenomenon it wasn't
like this was every time you go to the
pub some of them were joking with us
yeah we staged this for you because you
wanted music and you wanted campfire and
yeah and it you know obviously it was
not staged but um truly you know in the
this is a a pub with lots of rooms sort
of a Warren like situation and uh there
were three big tables in the room that
we were in and the fact that every
single one of these tables had an
instrument at them with people you know
with the violin to be pulled out first
like where did that come from from and
then for an accordion right accordion
came out I like where'd she even pull
that out from like how do you how do you
how do you cryptically carry around an
accordion you suddenly produce an
accordion and and but I mean also we had
heard and certainly we had heard before
and what we heard in the pub that night
with the music was consistent with the
claim that all check people and you know
presumbly it's not absolutely all but
certainly everyone there that night um
knows something like 30 or some people
said oh it's more than that uh check
folk songs that they can sing that and
are are interested in doing so when
conditions permit and so that's there's
something about having a shared culture
and specifically shared music that you
know when you sing together you come
together and you know it's very very
rare for Americans sitting around to
actually all know the lyrics to a single
song of any of any note you know aside
from the totally Bol in fact you and
I discovered how rare this is um in
taking students on field trips and
attempting to find a song that everybody
knew in common that they were willing to
sing around a campfire
and my recollection is unless you
specifically assigned people to find
such songs which was not easy for them
you know to provide lyrics for the
people who didn't know it that sort of
thing unless you specifically did that
there was really only one popular song
that students of you know these were
Millennials that we were
teaching um that they all knew and could
wrestle forth some shared version of
which was Wagon Wheel which is funny
because that's not it just has somehow
became the song that Evergreen students
on field trips knew right it yeah it was
but the degree to which people don't
have anything else to resort to because
what however much in love with music
they are it's some very independent
version of music right we have we have
such
diversity which in some ways has made
things more interesting musically but it
means that it's much harder to come
together around music and Zach is to say
but first I want to say you alluded to
it but on my first uh study abroad to
Ecuador um I ass you know all all the
students there was lots of work that we
were doing together but one of the
pieces of work that doesn't sound
academic at all is that I assigned all
of the students in advance and small
groups certain types of work that would
enhance the trip in ways that had
nothing to do with the formal academic
goals of the work and to I don't
remember if it was three or four
students I said you know you I want you
to basically you know solicit from the
class what what songs or what kinds of
songs they would be interested in
singing together because I knew that a
couple of my students were bringing
instruments I encouraged them to do so
on the trip and then you will produce
lyric sheets and you will bring C you
will you will have copies for everyone
and everyone is going to have copies of
these lyrics sheets and no one's ever
going to be required to sit around
singing that's this isn't a music class
um but there will be many opportunities
when we could be doing so and this will
mean that no one has the excuse of oh I
don't know the lyrics of that song Some
people may not know the particular song
but once you hear it a few times you you
you should be able to remember the tune
and if you have the lyrics in front of
you you can do it and it was wonderful
it was definitely the most musical of uh
any of my study abroad um yeah any of my
study abroad or even other field trips
so I want to say one thing before we uh
bring in Zach's Point here which is um I
have suggested not just with respect to
music but also with respect to
literature that there is a question
about is it more important that what
you're engaging with is of the highest
quality or that it is shared and I am no
longer convinced that um the sharedness
of it is in any way secondary that if
you were all reading the same uh books
in common or sub some some subset of the
books you were reading in common that it
creates a very different kind of um
ability to comprehend each other which
is May maybe fundamental to moving ahead
through time as an actual people
whatever discovered the Great books
curriculum well the question is are the
great books the great books or are the
great books Frozen in time and there are
other things that should be read but the
Canon may have to evolve but is there
value in having a Canon yes right and I
actually uh I would have suspected this
about music but having watched a Pub
full of checks who didn't know each
other uh erupt into song together and
watched the camaraderie and I think we
even felt the camaraderie not having any
idea what the content of these songs
actually was so seeing that mean you
know it's one of the things that we
quietly I don't even want to say we did
away with it we allowed it to be
destroyed because we didn't understand
it was a Chesterton fence issue right
and I would say couples dancing and it
wasn't it was like a chesterton's line
in the sand that you didn't notice it
wasn't even like oh we'll have to get
dismantled this it just we just let it
go we just let it go without imagining
uh the depth of the value and anyway um
it's a mistake we should not repeat if
if we manage to get ourselves through
this this rather dire time indeed um I
think this is less true in my generation
actually uh that there are a lot of
songs that I can end up around a
campfire with people I don't know uh
particularly well and everyone knows
it's not even just like two or three
it's a lot a lot of songs so uh and
songs that not um not music that you
would find Bol or un interesting music
that you guys listen to or have listened
to and interesting you care to provide
any examples or is that relevant not
going to be that great but Wagon Wheel
was the first one I was going to come up
with um Chasing Cars Rip Tide dad you
may know some of these anything by The
Lumineers pretty much okay um there are
a lot of them though uh and obviously
it's not like every single person will
know every song but there are some there
are a number of them that actually
pretty much everyone will know
interesting well I have a little
anecdote for you um I was teaching uh a
class with Rachel Hastings and um I for
whatever reason
I wanted students to think about what
song might represent their generation in
some way and I actually let's just be
clear this is a person one of these
crazy people with a doubl PhD uh so PhD
is in mathematics and Linguistics which
was the point of connection for you
teaching with with with her right so you
were probably doing like evolution of
like communication and language and such
yeah it it was it was evolution of
language in one way or another um so
cool cool teaching with linguists yeah
it is as well it is cool teaching with
linguist and in her case I forgive her
for having somehow pursued two phds
which ordinarily I would consider an
indication of a mental disorder but in
her case I think she was just being
thorough um but
anyway uh so I proposed a song I
forgotten which one it is exactly but it
happened to be a lumer song so again
these are millennials not gen Z's I
proposed a lumer song that I thought
more or less got at the ethos that I
detected from Millennials they
absolutely hated this suggestion they
detested it and the song that they did
so they knew it and hated the song
absolutely they couldn't stand the idea
that it might represent them and maybe
it doesn't but what they came up with
instead was um Gangam
Style which I did not have a deep
relationship with I had in fact heard it
but didn't really even understand what
it was and they explained to me what it
was what did they say well they said
that it was actually a sendup of this
very Tony Korean
neighborhood Tony Tony Tony fancy yeah
okay super fancy I'm like caramel
colored I don't English is not my first
Lang would just remember that but um but
anyway this very Tony uh Korean
neighborhood you know I'm imagining
something Beverly
[Music]
seeming to present an argument for
embracing it or something like that so
it's sort of a dripping with irony okay
over the top uh very I don't know if
you've seen the video for it never oh
it's pretty wild but um but anyway so
they thought that it was sort of they
were very tuned so The Lumineers are
pretty Earnest and I think the problem
was that I had suggested something
Earnest and they were much more in touch
with their cynicism and Gangam Style
represented their cynicism that may be
the description of the generation right
there rejection of earnestness Embrace
of cynicism yeah of of the Millennials
you know and not to say like again we
happened to teach exactly we had lots of
students who weren't traditional age but
if all of our students have been
traditional College age we taught the
Millennials yeah and almost to a person
our students were amazing um but I do
feel like the generation understood
itself to be um you know beyond post
Earnest post Earnest and Pro ISM yeah
Pro cynicism which uh raises my little
principle that uh no matter how cynical
you are you're still being naive the
whole damn generation was still being
naive no matter how in love with their
cynicism they were yeah indeed so I
guess the the one other thing that I
would um put just put out there as I
already have in writing Natural
Selections but about that evening at the
pub uh was that uh a couple of the
people who who we had just met that
night who had been there for the for the
book launch the book baptism
uh were two men who were basically Polar
Opposites politically uh and you know we
heard them discuss Trump and what was
going on in the schools and guns and
they had you know they just they could
have easily been Americans on opposite
side of the political spectrum and they
were sitting next to each other they
were drinking together they were
laughing together they ended up singing
together and you know they're not going
to be best buddies but they disagreed
and the world did not end and neither of
them thought that the other one was an
evil human being or a naive idiot um you
know depending on which which way it
might have gone and it felt like
something that would be very very hard
to find in the
US yeah it was remarkable I had
forgotten that that piece of it but
you're absolutely right that watching
people who vehemently disagreed over
consequential things but it did not it
was not personal um was uh a reminder of
how things are in better times so I mean
I guess as long as we're this deep in
the uh discussion here we should talk
about the model we were sort of playing
with about why this culture is where it
is and I I let me just say a couple more
things about that um you and I were not
necessarily expecting to find what we
found in Prague in fact we were
concerned based on where things are
historically about going to Europe at
this moment and because prag was our
first stop but London was our next stop
and we were concerned about being in
London in particular yep and we will
talk about the comparison but what was
striking about Prague um was that it
appeared to be a version of the West
that functions far better than any other
version that we have recently seen all
of the versions you know whether it's
Australia New Zealand Canada
Germany all of these places are now
severely messed up surrounding the very
values that once galvanized them as you
know the West so when we found that
Prague was quite the opposite that there
seemed to be a deep commitment to um
what what we have called uh
cosmopolitanism um as as a stark
contrast to multiculturalism
multiculturalism being you keep your own
culture and you live side by side with
people keeping their own culture whereas
cosmopolitanism uh yes you can keep your
Traditions but the point is you're part
of an agreement to move forward while
deemphasizing lineages and all of that
this appeared to be alive and well in
Prague and what we started to consider
was the possibility that the Iron
Curtain had actually so uh the Czech
people have an uncomfortable
relationship with whether they are west
or east because being behind the Iron
Curtain people assume that they are of
Eastern Europe and they don't see
themselves this way and that's true
because what you know the Soviets were
protecting themselves by collecting
satellite States as a buffer to prevent
attack and so effectively uh
Czechoslovakia got trapped behind the
Iron Curtain with a good deal of
westernness to it m and the hypothesis
that you and I were playing with um was
that the Iron Curtain actually protected
it from what has destroyed it in most of
the what the checks called the west west
Wester well one one one guy during the
Q&A of the book baptism and I I think
that was Charming the West the west west
and then the west west west which is
like out here on the frontier in the
west coast of the us where we went crazy
first or something craziest of all um
but anyway the idea is that the Iron
Curtain and I would argue that the thing
that destroyed the Western values in the
west west west was the relationship with
the market which does not mean that I am
anti-market long time viewers and
listeners will know that I'm extremely
pro market but I do not I draw a
distinction between allowing markets to
tell you how to do something no tool is
better than a market for getting you to
producing something that does a job well
but Market should never be allowed to
tell you what to do because they will
find every defect of human character and
exploit it and you will end up with uh a
dystopian nightmare if you let markets
Drive um but anyway that Force which
seems to have destroyed our values in
the west west west um was basically held
at Bay by you know communist
authoritarianism which is not a good
thing but nonetheless it protected in
some ways the way um the way the Embargo
and the relationship between Cuba and
the Soviet Union protected Cuban music
from what the music industry did to
music Across the rest of Latin America
and the world really yeah uh I I think
that analogy is fascinating um the one
to to Cuba and its musical tradition and
perhaps as well um with regard to the
Czech Republic of course uh that raises
the question of well what about all of
the other countries that the Soviet
Union was using his buffer that were
behind the Iron Curtain um and the Czech
Republic has you know we are not
historians but you know a number of
things that are unique and we say this
as people who have not been I I I had
been in Prague once before 97 and then
um a friend who I was attending a
conference with in Prague and I went
around um Hungary together uh so I had
have been in Hungary the countryside of
Hungary and Budapest and Prague once
before but 25 years ago uh and you had
not been in central eastern Europe at
all before um so the Czech Republic you
know why why does the Czech Republic
seem to be doing something rather
different from what Hungary is doing for
instance or Slovakia or you know or you
know any of the other countries that
were not um fully Soviet but effectively
being used as as buffers um by the
Soviet Union well in part the Czech
Republic is right at that Edge and so it
had borders uh that were not that it it
it contained The Border that was the
Iron Curtain effectively and um so it
had greater proximity there must have
been some sort of cultural osmosis
across osmosis across that border but
also the history of the Czech people in
particular which you mentioned the
language being so distinct so difficult
and so intact um has meant that
throughout a very long history of
effectively occupation like you know
Hungary was in charge of things for a
long time the Czech you know the Czech
people were under the boot of the austr
Hungarian Empire and they were under the
boot of the Russians and then the
Germans and then the Soviets and you
know before the austr Hungarian Empire
presumably there's you know it goes back
farther in time um but you know over and
over and over again the sort of the
noble subversion and the being able to
communicate just among themselves and
retaining retaining things like folk
songs and you know Cuisine that was like
I didn't I didn't go in there expecting
anything but like was really good and
unique distinct there's just a lot of
very distinct parts of Czech culture um
that would that would suggest that it
would be distinct from also other
countries uh that were behind the Iron
Curtain because that wouldn't be a
sufficient explanation right yeah I
don't think it is sufficient I think it
it is that something of the West got
trapped behind the Iron Curtain and that
I I think that there is a contrast that
we are going to find between Hungary and
the Czech Republic and
interestingly you and I raised this
point with all of the people that we
were meeting after we had started to
detect this because it was a real
question what has happened here why you
know for example we had walked some very
long distance one day and we came back
through uh a neighborhood and uh
families back and forth strollers you
know fathers holding their children's
hand walking down the street it was just
so normal so many children right it's
it's rare that you see almost any
children in American cities now yeah and
and there was just no evidence of the
nonsense the having forgotten what men
and women are and any of this it just
looked like it looked like a time
capsule M um so um I think the thing is
there are a couple different ways to
resist whatever the market or whatever
force it was if it wasn't the market did
to the values of the West one of them
has to do with unfortunately embracing a
kind of primitive lineage against
lineage notion which I think is you know
we haven't been to Hung Hungary you've
been there once but we haven't been
there lately but this is sort of what we
hear that you know that that is sort of
the it's you know a kind of uh reversion
to a prec
Cosmopolitan uh approach now if that's
unfair I'm interested but my guess would
be that there are two ways to resist
this one of these is the sort of
backward looking Hungarian way and the
other way is to actually uh the Czech
way the Cosmopolitan way to protect that
instinct towards this Western value and
figure out what it is that threatens it
and somehow Corral that Force so that
cosmopolitanism can go on because
frankly that's the only way we as a
planet are going to make it we're too
well armed to go back to isolating
ourselves by lineage and fighting right
as dumb as it would be to do that that
because it makes a much less Pleasant
world it's also suicidal yeah uh I guess
one other thing worth noting because we
didn't know what to expect with regard
to um how uh Prague uh was looking in
the wake of October 7 and we knew we
were going to London next and there was
already um you know real explicit uh
protest and and worse um that was Pro
Hamas and and we really saw the opposite
in Prague um and in fact we saw one and
I on an independent walk saw another of
the you know long wall of these flyers
that have been being put up from people
who of people who were kidnapped on
October 7th from Israel by Hamas which
you know we've been if you've been
online at all uh you have heard that in
many places and you know in London in
many American cities there are people
going around tearing down these flyers
um and you know really no matter what
you think no no matter what you think
people being kidnapped from from their
lives and being held hostage uh is is an
act of
barbarism and in Prague uh these flyers
were uh Immaculate there were long lines
of them they weren't being guarded by
police they were on public streets where
they easily could have been de defaced
or vandalized instead what I saw on the
uh when when I ran into one set of these
when I wasn't with you uh was that
people who were walking you know on
their way somewhere check people were
actually pausing in front of some of
them to to look at some of them that
this was this had become part of sort of
the background understanding of this is
part of what's going on in the world and
we're going to reflect and respect uh
this Truth by observing it and then
continuing on um I don't perhaps that is
happening elsewhere I hope it is
happening elsewhere but to have seen
that response to these flyers in person
person was um extraordinary yeah uh
we'll maybe get to this a little later
in the discussion but
the outpouring of anti-Semitism that has
been seen around the globe means that
whatever uh latent anti-Semitism was
there is suddenly activated and on the
surface and so I was
expecting absolutely expecting that we
would see some of it and maybe it would
be less or more who knew um but I was
not expecting to detect its opposite and
by its opposite I mean and I'm not
arguing that there was never
anti-Semitism in the Czech Republic
there clearly was but what remains there
seems to
be um a genuine sense of affinity and in
fact
a palpable sense of regret over the Jews
who were liquidated by the Nazis from
uh from what would have been
Czechoslovakia yeah
um and I did not expect that at all I
did not expect it but um that is the
feeling and also just interacting with
people there was
no there was nothing to feel right
people it it really was this
Cosmopolitan feeling um so anyway that's
heartening that somewhere is not beset
by this and I will also say that um
the
feeling this is has only one part of
this has anything to do with
anti-Semitism but the feeling of safety
walking around Prague was also unusual
um a a stark contrast to any American
city at the moment which is shocking and
not just safety but um at one point we
were we were on a long walk back from um
actually the the day that we were
invited to um do the the the cold plunge
with a couple of our new friends in the
river and then we went and had lunch and
then we walked back uh some some number
of miles back to the Airbnb where we
were staying and walked back through a
number of neighborhoods we hadn't been
in before and we're at some very busy
sort of Pedestrian Mall I don't like
that word but sort of you a large area
with no with no traffic uh except for
the trams that were going through the
street cars that were going through one
one place and we just stood there for a
while watching people and after 10 15
minutes you said there's no drama no
drama at all and this was a pretty
diverse uh setting like there were some
tourists among the Czechs who were not
you know somewhat homogeneous with
regard to their ethnicity but um this
was you know young old black white you
know you presumably very well off and
not so well off uh and families single
people old people couples and no drama
zero drama people would occasionally
bump into each other like just just
nothing everyone was just doing their
thing living their lives being being
nice being friendly some of them were
clearly not in fantastic moods and some
of them were in amazing moods and
neither of them tried to infect the
others uh with whatever it was that they
had yeah I in
watching it occurred to me that they
just weren't focused on each other right
they were not obsessed with what other
people were going to think of them or
wer being performative yeah they weren't
broadcasting their politics right they
were just being and it was s it was such
it was a they weren't just not focused
on each other they weren't focused on
their own identity right so it what they
as you said they weren't broadcasting
this is who I am you have to know who I
am at all times and like no they just
are right they just are and it
was you know you and I have talked many
times about the strange culture shock
that you get not necessarily when you go
someplace really different but when you
come home and you can see your own
culture briefly for what it is um this
was a reminder of a state of
being that I I just haven't seen in so
long yeah people just just being and not
you know I don't even know how else to
describe it but it would you don't know
that that's not what's going on in an
American Park until you've gone
somewhere and watched it happen and it's
like oh that's 25 years ago right the
last time I saw that is 25 years ago M
um so what the hell happened and you
know obviously why we let it go yeah why
did we let it go uh there's also I mean
what one additional piece is that uh
there appears to be no opiod crisis yeah
uh in in really almost in all of Europe
we are told um but definitely not uh in
Prague tiny amount of homelessness no
obvious yeah but you know whereas in
Portland you know I actually asked
someone like where are the people lying
in the street with their pants around
their ankles half joking but seriously
in West Coast cities that's what you see
and uh people in prag thought I was
joking yes you also and who knows what
has to do with what but you also in um
watching people either in the park or in
this uh yeah Mall of a terrible ped but
yeah some shopping district with no cars
in it um with a guy who was making fire
out of his mouth Yes from Poland yeah um
the fire wasn't from Poland he didn't
say but
um the uh much reduced obsession with
phones yeah right people are obviously
using their phones they have the same
phones the rest of us do they're
connected to the same internet but you
know the people walking around were
actually living their lives rather than
physically present but mentally
elsewhere um so that was interesting as
well and you know what does that have to
do with them having become not
performative and not being obsessed with
what other people think of them at every
moment probably a lot
yes yes indeed um all right you have
more to say about uh no I think we've
done a pretty good I mean we probably
returned to it but uh something
interesting is going on there and uh
a it was a delightful departure from
what has become The New Normal a
delightful and unexpected departure from
The New Normal um at many different
levels it was you know I didn't know
that Czech food was a thing um but Czech
food while not being you know a stunning
Cuisine
was delicious every meal they were not
things that you would necessarily
encounter elsewhere it was the whole
thing was pretty eye open and we had
chican food did have J food one night it
was late and we in the one check
restaurant we went to was going to be a
long wait and so we're like somehow we
ended up in a Mexican restaurant and
having grown up in La that was probably
a stupid Mo like you just don't go eat
Mexican food if you both grew up in LA
and have also spent a lot of time in
Mexico and actually like real like
Mexican street food but we did it and it
was not a mistake it was in retrospect
not a it was definitely a mistake on the
front end because why are you doing that
but it was a pretty darn good I mean
I've never been served tacos with gravy
before they're right that's not it was
actually really really good and when we
mentioned this to uh I me Eva like I I
don't remember one of our one of our new
friends the next day and you know we had
said you know is it is it cchm like what
is it it's cican like yeah all right
yeah all right then we went to London
yeah then we went to London things are
different um things are different things
are different I would say London felt um
still much more functional than uh the
major West Coast cities yeah um we did
run into
uh some protests there were a couple of
massive protests while we were there um
and we ran into people you know proudly
displaying Palestinian Flags wearing
them in fact uh on the tube yeah one guy
draped draped in a Palestinian flag
being filmed by his associate yeah which
you know under ordinary
circumstances um I wouldn't think twice
about it or maybe I would think twice
about it it's weird to be draped in a
flag to be draing a flag but I guess the
point is you
know it's the West right you do you you
do you um on the other hand uh the fact
that these protests appear to be
supportive of the worst barbarism in uh
recent
memory uh is obviously very striking
yeah we worried before we went uh about
whether we would feel safe and I don't
think I if we had run into one of these
massive protests you know at Big Ben or
or the like it would have been different
so I was on the tube on Saturday um
going went to get an eye appointment
because it's easier and cheaper to do
that in London than it is in the United
States that tells you something about
our Health Care system because theirs is
not in great shape either but um I was
on the tube alone and then you were
going to be meeting me out out there and
um very crowded and I didn't know then
that I think it was crowded precisely
because um you know
the line that I was on several stops
after I was getting off was going to
Westminster and this was going to be the
massive protest and there were several
people who got on with um big unfurled
banners in Arabic whereing cfas and such
and um it you know that's had had I you
know Gone Gone to Westminster instead of
getting off at my stop um I think it
might we I might have felt a little
different although not being Jewish um
and
um you I I think I would have been
utterly fine but people who were in the
middle of it had a different experience
to be sure um I I do think this all
brings into Stark relief this
distinction between multiculturalism and
the Cosmopolitan West and that you know
what you're looking at in
Europe is a disagreement over what it
means to live together
and
the I don't know how it is that one
advances the right idea my feeling
is I'm cool with anybody who is up for
figuring out how we get along and put
aside the racial stuff doesn't mean
forget where you came from it doesn't
mean give up your Traditions but the
point is either we're going to get along
and we're going to be productive because
we're we not focused on that as a
delineator of who is tolerable or worth
collaborating with or not or we aren't
and the problem is that
multiculturalism sounds like a synonym
for cosmopolitanism but it is in fact
the opposite and I think this is
something we have to increasingly be
concerned about that one of the ways
that the label doesn't match what's in
the box is that something is disguised
as its opposite and that causes people
to either just not pay attention because
it's too complex to figure out what the
hell is going on you know the Patriot
Act was very unpatriotic right um
multiculturalism sounds like yeah I dig
multiculturalism you know I love Indian
food and I sure have enjoyed traveling
in Latin America Multicultural is the
next guy nope multiculturalism is about
insulation and that is why it is so
dangerous because the point is if you
you know if we're supposed to live
together but you're going to retain your
obligation to some other thing then the
point is well we're not even really a
nation are we and I'm not arguing that
this is in any way a simple question
it's really not because for one thing um
let's take for
example uh Asian minorities in countries
of the traditional West um these folks
often live in enclaves that take on the
cultural attributes of their Homeland is
that something to be worried about I
don't think so yeah because talking
about like chinatowns right Chinatown
Japan toown whatever it is because I
think what's going on if I understand
these places correctly and I've
certainly been to dozens of
them the
immigrants retain their culture in these
enclaves but they don't expect their
children to live within Japan to town
and to you know to not be of their host
nation the point is it's a it's a
transition period in the same way that
um when two people who do not speak the
same language find themselves working
the same field having to coordinate with
each other they develop what's called a
pigeon a linguistic pigeon which is not
a complete language but it allows them
to exchange enough information to to
function and the point is a pigeon is
not aha we've arrived at you know the
intersection between um between Swedish
and French the point is it's a it's a
stop Gap measure and immigrants you
don't expect immigrants to
suddenly be of their new culture
especially if the gap between cultures
is Big um but the question is is the
commitment actually I do I'm moving
there because I want to be of that place
that's why I'm going through the effort
of moving is that I actually think that
that place is the place for me and my
family going going forward that's the
Cosmopolitan view even if it takes a
temporary stop as well the people who've
come from that culture are going to live
in the same place because they speak
each other's language and they know how
to get things done um but that's the
real question is you know are you going
to keep your children separate from your
new culture right and I don't mean just
teach them the traditions and feed them
the food of the Homeland I mean is is
your priority to keep them from becoming
part of your new culture that's the
issue well I
guess there's presumably a distinction
for people who uh are seeking to go to
say the United States uh because they
understand the United States to be a
place where they want to be as opposed
to needing to whether or not the need is
uh merely felt or absolutely um
absolutely true um escape from the place
that they are from and finding United
States or wherever it is a place that
they can go and so I would you know I
would certainly expect that people in
the first group uh would be more
encouraging of their children uh to both
um hold on to the cultures of of their
Homeland and also um become you know
become American uh whereas uh the people
in the second group while perhaps having
some gratitude for having found Safe
Harbor uh may not be nearly as excited
about actually um having any members of
their family become American because you
know they don't feel like it was a
choice like you know they were forced
out of the place that they wanted to be
and it still feels like home to them um
yeah I agree and again uh I don't want
to pretend that there is any obviousness
to how one addresses these distinctions
but there is a distinction between
effective refugees right right um who
aren't moving by choice they're getting
out of the way of something which is of
course perfectly understandable um and I
would point out that one of the things
that we learned about about the Czech
Republic is that it had it had absorbed
a large number of Ukrainian refugees
huge number in a population of 10,000
Czech 10 million Czech people uh they
apparently accepted 500,000 Ukrainian
refugees right interestingly there was
no there was a little detectable tension
over this there had been concern that
there might be tension but the fact is
this functioning culture had absorbed a
huge fraction of refugees um and had
done so in a way that had not been
massively disruptive or had had not
caused uh a cultural
crisis now the ukrainians and the Czech
people are not so distinct from one
another um you know not nearly as
distinct as some of the cultures that
are coming into clash with one another
as refugees com to countries but I do
think unfortunately we have become
unwilling to discuss the difficult
issues surrounding things like
patriotism does it make you know and I
will just remind people this is one of
these terms I've redefined for myself
because it needed redefining in order to
do precise enough work so what I mean by
patriotism does not inherently apply to
a nation you patriotism is a willingness
to sacrifice on behalf of something
bigger and more important than you are a
nation is one such thing but it's not
the only such thing but in any case
the idea that a
nation has a right to to wonder whether
or not you are actually hostile when you
move into this new Homeland or aspire to
be part of it that is an obvious
question yes and to the extent that you
know the open borders folks for example
right open boarders sounds so lovely you
know oh there's an open border between
Washington and Oregon that's just that's
how it should be Globe wide
well maybe one day but not while people
are hostile to each other in a way that
the border is the place where you take
those folks who bear ill will towards
you or to some fraction of you and
exclude them because it's the good thing
for the nation to exclude them at the
border right once you're inside then
obviously the questions of equal rights
are fundamental but um at the border
that's the place where a nation you know
wouldn't it be wonderful if cells didn't
have to have membranes right well this
is what I was just thinking you know
like to what degree can can we go
reductio absurdum on this and say you
know all all borders all fences all
categorizations are wrong and I do I do
feel like in some academic classrooms
that is where this goes like you know I
think there was an argument and at some
level you could say that this is you
know the sex as a construct and male and
female are you know all in your mind is
perhaps perhaps a a logical if insane uh
Downstream consequence of this kind of
thinking yeah it's one of a million
failure modes Downstream of Marxism yeah
right the basic point is well okay uh
the the uh cargraphic version of from
each according to his ability to each
according to his need is borderlessness
yes the point is you go where you want
take from them because if they've got
more and you've got less then obviously
it's their obligation to just hand it
over over um the point is no no one has
ever come up with a coherent mechanism
for actually doing this in a way that it
leaves a society uh tolerable the only
way to make it work since it punishes
those who contribute more and rewards
those who contribute less is uh with uh
the Iron Fist of authoritarianism to
keep people from RE rebelling against it
um
so obviously you've got to have a border
you're responsible for setting the rules
inside of your border hopefully you do
so so in a way that it enhances the
lives of the people inside of that
border so they become safer and more
secure and liberated and all of those
things but if you if you don't have a uh
a place where you stop the influx of
people who are not on board with your
rules then it's you know not shocking
when your rules Come Apart because of
incoherence right
so anyway I don't know I don't know
exactly where that um leaves us but I do
think
recognizing there's been a trap set for
us and it's always the case isn't
it when you hear about
multiculturalism and you think it's like
peer review right oh of course I'm what
who doesn't want their work reviewed by
peers right of course I'm in favor of
peer review you know uh you know is my
medicine evidence-based oh you betcha
right these are all science data driven
right data driven gosh I mean that
sounds so very empirical MH um I'm going
to follow that data oh follow it to the
end of the Earth yeah it just sounds
like these are things the mind so
quickly assumes it knows what these
words mean when placed together in this
way that it does not ask any questions
because to ask any questions would be to
evidence that maybe you're not fully on
board with empirical science are you
right right maybe you maybe you don't
want your work scrutinized because they
can't take it that kind of thing and so
anyway multiculturalism is one of these
things yep almost everybody uh uh of the
West has sort of just accepted it
because they know that they like some
Cuisine that isn't from their Homeland
and so they they aspire to
multiculturalism not realizing it's a
trojan horse right what they're really
aspiring to is Western
cosmopolitanism which you
know people can't see that these are
opposites and we have to if we're to go
forward so anyway I think I've more or
less said it but um but wow what a trag
that uh we are this confused about these
issues indeed so we were in London uh
largely to attend the ark conference uh
the alliance for responsible citizenship
about which uh much has been said and I
don't know that we're going to say that
much here but uh do you want
to yeah I mean let's say I think like
the rest of the world we became aware
that there was going to be an arc
conference before it was named that uh
when Peterson mentioned his his intent
to build such a thing uh on Joe Rogan's
podcast and it sounded like a tremendous
uh opportunity and indeed what they put
on um was in many regards quite stunning
it was uh as high a production value
conference as I've ever been to and it
wasn't small you would imagine the
highest production value conference
would have been a tiny one and no this
one was um huge yeah something like 13,
1400 people yeah it was really uh quite
something followed by a uh an event at
the O2 Arena which is a big Sports Arena
um with Jordan Peterson and Douglas
Murray and uh BN lomborg and Jonathan P
Jonathan Pou and Ben Shapiro guest
appearance by Ben Shapiro um so anyway
this was uh quite the cultural
moment um and you know it definitely had
a bent to it uh they were presenting a
particular perspective and it's one
about which uh there's a lot to be said
both positive and negative um but anyway
interesting that this is being attempted
yeah and I I will say um two two
positive things about uh about what we
both saw I won't speak for you but I
think you and I both were impressed uh
with a focus on Art um that the spoken
word poet whose name do you remember um
cont but I forgotten it yeah um who did
a couple of um spoken word poems was out
standing truly outstanding uh and I've
also forgotten the name of the uh artist
uh whose paintings were a little hard to
decipher they were large paintings on
either side of the stage hard to
decipher when you were far away from
them but his presentation on um the
various ways that art speaks to us uh
and also there was a composer who spoke
about the the role of cre creativity in
uniting uh past present and
future understandings uh all of those I
found very very compelling so that
thread that focus on Art I thought was
uh important and necessary um and I also
I mean I I'd heard the term before but
I'm and I'm certain you knew a lot more
and still do about this than than I did
but I had never actually heard anyone
present on fourth gen nuclear before and
so there was this one one little segment
um on um on energy um and uh there are a
couple of short presentations that were
um terrific including a description of
uh fourth generation nuclear which made
me wonder um as I have wondered before
but now much more sharply to who wins by
conflating second gen nuclear with
fourth gen nuclear like you know why is
it nuclear industry exactly so you why
is it that we're St still talking about
nuclear as if that's a thing when what
that immediately calls to mind for
almost everyone is dangerous and
outdated and and toxic and there is a
totally different thing uh that is that
is soon to be possible that is under
active development and uh it somehow
under the same umbrella and who wins the
current the second gen nuclear industry
right now it's not the funny thing is
you know it's new and it's Cutting Edge
and it's only 50 years old that it's
actually been uh possible to do right
this isn't this isn't do this isn't Fus
it actually has been done and I believe
I don't know but I believe that
basically there were a couple of
reactors that used this technology that
were then shut down and so you know the
uh the uranium folks are in charge still
of the nuclear industry um but we will
see now there's also a lot to be said
about what we don't know forth gen
nuclear looks to be a great deal safer
and uh more reasonable from the point of
view of burning spent nuclear fuel from
uranium baseda reactors for example um
you know uh melting down to a safe State
rather than a catastrophic failure um
but the question is what don't we know
right you know uranium is the devil we
do know um I don't know of anything that
suggests that fourth gen would be uh
similarly destructive and hazardous um
I guess these are discussions for
another time that we should definitely
have um but it was interesting to see
that also there was fascinating uh
presentation on um a cactus biomass
proposal that uh frankly I mean that
sounds almost Preposterous in terms of
its utility awesome actually and and the
the the the awesome guy behind it sent
me some pictures of of him at the cactus
farm but it's it looks like it could
actually do tremendous amount of good to
basically turn turn I think it was the
cactus pads into both um feed and
biofuel um both like feed for cattle and
such and biofuel you know basically
taking um non apparently nonuseful land
non-arable land and and what did you
call it sustainable solar sustainable
solar yeah I I think this is the way to
think of it because of course you know
as Michael shellenberger who was present
uh has pointed out
um solar is one of these
technologies that if you just pay
attention to the fact that some thing
that you stuck out in the sun is
spitting out electricity it looks
beautiful but when you
consider what it takes to make one of
these photovoltaic cells what it takes
to dispose of it what its lifetime is
right this is not as good a technology
as you would like I'm still very
favorable to solar of course Cactus is a
great technology and it's solar the
point is it's solar done in a way that
you don't have to do anything because
it's self-renewing um so anyway it's
already figured out all the glitches yes
it's already figured out all the
glitches and actually this was one of
the excellent points made by Chris
Martinson in the podcast that we
released a few weeks ago while we were
away um where you know he points out
that effectively nature is the only one
doing these things sustainably and that
you know wind farms and solar these are
rebuildable right um but they're not
sustainable because they don't maintain
themselves only plants do that so
anyway I'm I'm I'm I'm going to be
thrilled and tickled to discover that
Cactus was the solution to some big part
of our problem um I'm I'm I'm rooting
for that for reasons that are not you
know just about energy yeah oh totally
um I'm GNA I think I think it was Opus
I'm going to look it up and put and put
that in the in the show notes as well
right so people can find it um so we've
been gone for a while should we um
should we talk a little bit about what I
was doing in Denver or should we save
that for next time should we do that now
um that's your call yeah myel does Zach
have an opinion no he does not um okay
we'll we'll do it now questions there a
bunch of questions um well I'd like to
ask the audience but you can't respond
they can they can shake their fist at
the at the screen um how about this how
about I just um preview it and then
we'll come back to it okay so um from
from London uh I flew to Denver uh and
uh to give a talk at the Jens spect
conference uh Jens spect is an
organization set up uh to to talk
reality about sex and gender and to uh
to promote non-medicalized uh responses
to people with issues of of of
gender and it was um boy hopeful and
heartbreaking both as as which is the
phrase I think I used in my natural
selection piece yesterday
um one of the sets of things uh so there
there are I don't know I'm guessing 300
people 250 300 people in attendance and
a lot of parents of uh beloved children
who have um come to believe that they
are the sex that they are not a lot of
therapists a number of uh medical
professionals uh not people who are
actually um people who are trying to
resist the ideology and and and not not
prescribe hormones and and certainly not
uh promote surgeries uh for these for
these kids and and young adults uh and
the maybe I'll save um I'll save talking
about um sex equity for infant care
until next time that's the little teaser
um but I will share one of the parents I
talked to sent me a document that she is
anonymized enough that she uh said I can
I can share but I don't want you to show
my screen Zach I'm going to read some of
it but uh do not share my screen because
I'm not sure to what degree um it of the
trans identified Shooter had been
released by uh what's it Steven Crowder
a day or two ago yep uh and and this mom
and I had talked a day or two before
that and she sent this to me and said in
light of that
um and she's left out all identifying
characteristics so the exact the exact
reason that she felt compelled to send
this to me is not utterly clear but let
me just share some of what she she had
to say again this is this is written by
a mother um names and some identifying
features have been
changed um Mara's daughter Belle has
suffered from depression anxiety
suicidal ideation attempted suicide self
harm substance abuse and defiant
Behavior since the age of 11 therapy and
medication has had only limited success
a year and a half ago shortly after her
16th birthday she left home and moved to
a city 5 hours away to live with her
aunt
at that time Belle came out as
transgender took on a boy's name cut her
hair started wearing boy clothing her
aunt who was supportive of her
transition bought her chest binders and
enrolled her in the local high school as
a boy against the urging of Belle's
therapist her aunt was in no hurry to
continue Belle's therapy she believed
that there was nothing wrong with
Belle's mental health and that all Belle
needed was a supportive environment
unconditional love and to be accepted
for who she was this is the affirmative
care model right um which oh let me say
that um one of the speakers um a
remarkable young woman uh a d
transitioner uh
spoke uh now I'm not reading from this
spoke at the conference about the
distinction between affirmation and
validation and uh was arguing in favor
of validation which sounds like you know
what's the difference but the
distinction that she made this is this
is a natal female who lived uh as a as
as a man for some years and is now
detransitioned um and is you know coming
to be comfortable again in her female
body uh she said validation um is I
validate that you having the exper the
feelings that you say you are having and
affirmation is and your feelings are
real and true and reflection reflection
of physical reality yes and so you know
validation of yes I I have no I I if you
tell me you are feeling those things you
are feeling those things um but
affirmation takes that a step an
illogical step further and says um
you're feeling feelings are reflective
of reality which some feelings are and
some feelings aren't it is certainly not
true that all feelings are um so here we
have Belle's Aunt so they just so I have
the distinction it's affirmation versus
validation yeah and the affirmation
affirmative care model is what is being
pushed as the only appropriate model now
in medical and clinical and therapeutic
settings where you must affirm you you
must affirm as reality uh whatever
anyone says when they come into your
office in terms of what their identity
is
so that's it's affirmation and
validation is okay you're having those
feelings that doesn't make them
reflective of reality yeah that's uh the
the words aren't different enough to
necessarily remember but but but it's
it's memorable it's memorable that we
can say I hear you yeah I believe that
you're having those feelings without
then taking the extra step and saying
and therefore your feelings are
reflective of reality yeah it it it's
unfortunately a little bit like like uh
cosmopolitanism versus multiculturalism
in the sense that the terms could be
swapped and you have to remember which
is which right right okay so back to
this um this Mother's story um where
Belle is the 16-year-old who has uh Gone
five hours away to her aunt's house and
her aunt is saying that she's going to
provide unconditional love and to be
accepted for who she was and so she's
now um effectively helping her niece
Trans in um socially um um and uh
ultimately chemically um Belle's cut off
almost all contact with Belle's parents
because they were not supportive of her
transition she feared that they were try
to fix Belle she believed their views
were abusive and the cause of Belle's
problems she believed that she needed to
protect Belle from her parents this too
is a theme that we hear over and over
and over again of the system decides U
with the affirmative care model the
system decides it is the parents who
know their child and who love their
child deeply
and who want more than anything to
support their child and and be close
with them again and protect their child
the system decides that if they do not
go along with a uh Sudden Change of
identity um that they are the biggest
risk to the child and even the cause of
the child's problems which is which is
Despicable last week Bell was picked up
by police under a special warrant and
forcefully taken to a locked psychiatric
unit
over the last few months she had been
hospitalized twice for manic episodes
and had developed an obsession with guns
knives and violence on her tumbler
account she posted pictures of death
Gore and suicide some of the vest images
on the Internet Posting up to 100
pictures a day in her diary her aunt
found something so terrifying she called
the
police Mara the mom prepared a
letter um I'm actually going to skip
this part because it goes on for well
but she prepared a letter to read at the
risk assessment Committee of Bell's High
school um but in the end she decided
um against preparing presenting her
letter to the committee because the
school board supports the current
transgender ideology and if she'd read
the letter she knew she would be viewed
as abusive and blamed for causing Bill's
problems um instead she sat quietly and
answered their questions being careful
to refer to her daughter using the new
boy's name and male
pronouns after the meeting the principal
commended her for making the effort to
accept her daughter for who she was and
to love her uncond traditionally and
actually presumably it was for who he
was right because it's the it's the
delusional principle saying this Mara's
sister the aunt who helped this teenager
transition will not allow Belle back in
her house out of fear for her own safety
so the aunt helped create a monster out
of someone with known mental health
problems and now is washing her hands
with the whole thing so Bella is now
homeless living in a city five hours
from her
home in a city where the only person
that she knows is her aunt who will no
longer let her enter her house and the
final paragraph is Mara the mom sleeps
with a little bag packed ready to leave
at a moment's notice she's waiting for
the call from whom she does not know the
hospital the police the school she does
not know but she knows it will come and
so she
waits it's
terrifying
this mother is having a very particular
and individual
experience and this experience is
repeated with slightly different details
with largely different details over and
over and over and over again because of
what we are letting happen because we
have principles and school boards and
therapists and doctors who say
affirmative care model is the only thing
and if you feel like a donut today
you're a donut and of course if you said
donut it wouldn't work but the only way
this the only only one that they believe
is I feel like the sex I am not
and you know as is obvious as I said in
the talk that I gave here as we have
said many times there is very little
that is binary in biology there is very
very little that is binary but sex is
the exception sex is binary and in our
lineage um you cannot switch what sex
you are we have chromosomal sex
determination and and the sex that we
are is the sex that we are and we can
play our own gender Norms as much as we
want honestly um but that doesn't change
the sex that we
are so um at the point that
Bell uh became focused on violence yeah
what was the level of her so-called
transition I believe it's not it's not
in this letter but I believe from talk
talking to her mother um that she was on
testosterone so there's
a it's obviously implicit in what you
described but the
idea I mean let's just first be clear
about the biology here
yeah your parents are the best shot you
have at somebody who is truly on your
team at the highest possible level and
the reason for that is because each one
is 50% genetically related to you and
while that is true statistically of your
siblings as well your full
siblings they are also your competitors
in a manner of speaking yeah and that is
not to say that siblings do not
overwhelmingly have each other's
interests at heart but it means that
there is a well understood conflict that
comes uh from the fact that resources
are limited and in any case
your parents are also a generation
removed which basically their hope of
getting their genes deeply into the
future which is of course what they are
wired to do whether they know it or not
um goes through their children and then
their
grandchildren so while you cannot be
certain and there are lots of bad
parents out there your parents are the
best shot at having somebody truly on
your team until you sign up with a
partner and if you do it right then that
person becomes truly on your team
because their best shot at getting their
genes into the future depends on your
partnership so what is happening
here is that the state is participating
in a rebellion against parents that
liberates people who are
not in a position I mean these are
people who are specifically going to be
Unwell by their own definition if you're
born into the wrong body that's not well
so the point is if that's what you think
you are you're telling us that something
is way off MH so the state is
emancipating people who are in this
precarious
State
um the chemical fact that somehow in
emancipating people that the state is
participating in requiring affirmative
care another label doesn't fit what's in
the box um is going to result in a
disruption of people who are
unwell in a direction that at least some
of the time is going to lean towards
things for which this person has no
developmental capacity to control them
because they're not native to that
person so it's not surprising at all
that this would be a result doesn't mean
it's Universal but it means it's
certainly on the list of possibilities
that you would expect to see
further and I think you were very early
on spotting this the degree to which
there's a standard Pharma Ploy in here
the idea of hey we can define something
that is commonplace let's say gender
dysphoria we can Define it as a malady
for which we just happen to have a
chemical treatment and what we need is
an immunity from the consequences of
administering this uh super weapon that
is not targeted right we don't know
enough about biology to intervene
post-development to change your sex even
if we understood what that meant right
we just have blunt tools at best um but
the idea that Pharma is going to create
a pathology right why do I say creative
pathology because we know that most
people who have gender dysphoria as
young people grow out of it so why
aren't we letting them grow out of it
because we're obligated to help them
become who they really are as if that
makes any sense and if you
transition and do not desist or
detransition you are a pharmaceutical
customer for life right a pharmace you
are a patient for life and a
pharmaceutical customer for life and
that is a win for the pharmaceutical
company and a lose for you yeah it's a
kind of
um chemical brand
loyalty
um and the idea that you have a mother
who represents presumably many such
mothers looking in horror at the fact
that
her
emancipated child has now been
interfered with is now a danger to
herself and others and is in no position
to do anything about it because the fact
of that emancipation means that a parent
in a very difficult situation doesn't
have the tools to to address it so you
know what what is the
obligation of society to the potential
victims that this person might go after
because of their delusional violent
fantasies right those people at this
moment are walking around unaware that
there's a ticking time bomb out there
without a home uh
having uh violent fantasies I mean this
couldn't be more obvious and yet we're
going to continue to do
it it felt at this conference and I I
will come back and talk a bit more about
some of the um more hopeful things that
I heard um on our next live stream next
Tuesday
um but it did feel like the tide is
turning a bit as much as uh we heard
public presentations and I heard many
private stories about
the the grief and and the the wreckage
that is being being done in the name of
science and medicine and equity and
inclusion and I don't even know what um
it does feel that many many people are
waking up and seeing it um at the same
time
that courts in many places are still
school districts and therapists and
medical professionals and courts in many
places are actually holding holding
children hostage um allowing one parent
uh to destroy a child even as much as
presumably those parents don't think
that's what they're doing but one parent
to destroy a child while the other
parent fights fiercely to not let it
happen but because now the default
assumption is if your child says they're
TR trans and you say they're not you are
wrong that has become the default
assumption and that is
horrible yeah um now I must say I think
part of the reason that people are
waking up is that um The Blue Team which
cynically went along with this stuff uh
has decided to distance itself from the
woke Revolution that it created and this
is obviously uh one of the major themes
of that
Revolution but I also think what happens
exactly when all of these people who
have been LED halfway through such a
story are abandoned because suddenly the
team that did this is pretending they
have no responsibility to these people
who they have to differing degrees uh
destroyed what comes next because those
people have every right to be very angry
yes and there are lawsuits the lawsuits
are beginning and that's that's a good
sign too it it is a good sign but I
guess my point would be there are too
many people who have been compromised at
too high a level um and I think what
we're going to see
unfortunately is a rerun of the battle
over people dying
suddenly right yeah people dying
suddenly there is an absurd campaign to
portray this as normal or the result of
some mysterious thing that we haven't uh
figured out but it's nothing to worry
about because you know it's either not
happening or uh you know kids get
strokes I mean it's just you know it's
true right um that thing these people
are now going to be gaslit that
andil and gas them or not
theyed at the moment the D transitioners
are ignored and rebuffed and belittled
um but the transitioners at the point
that the tide turns are going to be
gaset they are going to be gaset and
even worse think about the various
factions that
um owe them something so many you've got
Pharma which is going to be very focused
on uh its legal liability so it's going
to have a massive campaign to prevent
anybody from connecting dots that are
sitting right next to each other well
and I'm sure that there were a lot of
things signed by people in desperation
to finally have all of their problems
solved by just taking these cross- sex
hormones and that that releases
liability I'm I'm I'm sure whatever
tools they could arrange they will have
arranged those folks in the community of
trans folks are going to reject these
people at the highest possible level
because of course d-transition has
always been the greatest crime um the
people who went along with this garbage
are going to play the middle ground
scramble thing right where they're going
to you know find some mechanism for
evading their own failures and
responsibility and so uh you know you
all of these people are going to be gas
that and cut a drift from all of these
people who owe them something and and uh
you know it's an unthinkable nightmare
it is it really
is okay um I will come back on our next
live stream with
um something that ends up just being so
ridiculous that we have to laugh sex
equity for infant care um let say
democratizing breastfeeding you know I'm
prepared to laugh at it but less so now
that I know that it's the infants
demanding it yeah yes Now They Are Up In
MH arms and actually since they're
unable to walk up in arms and legs over
the inequities of breastfeeding yeah
yeah yeah well we we'll go there next
time um in the meantime we will do uh a
Q&A here all right shortly uh we'll come
back in about 15 minutes and do a live
Q&A you can ask questions at Darkhorse
subm missions.com and here's just a
little bit of other things about places
where you can find us join us at locals
we've got so many benefits and more all
the time we do we put our uh guest
episodes that Brett has with awesome
people up 24 hours early there we do our
private monthly Q&A uh there on locals
uh we did not manage while we were in
proger London together to do anything
but we do occasional impromptu ask me
anything um uh you've done some Zach and
I did one maybe we'll do that again that
was fun um and you can access our
Discord server there you can still
access the Discord server on our
patreons but we're encouraging people to
move over to to
locals we've got um
oh Darkhorse store uh where uh Jake's
micro Pizza uh is uh the t-shirts
advertising Jake's micro Pizza are
available you know I will put on my mask
when I'm done eating you just can't see
that I'm eating because the pizza is
just that small it's very small it's
very tiny but delicious so good yeah so
good hypoallergenic oh of course y mhm
cheese free wheat free it's not cheese
free man we use only the highest quality
cheese but no wheat I thought it was
cheese free I thought I thought you were
encourag we have a peas free version
yeah it's done with cauliflower but
um we'll get our ducks and row on Jake's
micro pizza here any yeah yeah um
because we just did the baptism of our
book in check uh bear is mentioning
Hunter gathers guide of the 21st century
is now over two years old but it's
available in lots and lots of languages
including check including Czech now it's
a best seller in the Czech Republic we
didn't mention that I probably have the
page up somewhere it's awesome um
uh they also Institute h21 also
published nen strawson's most recent
book in check uh so we are in good
company lovely to discover a publisher
that is actually so deeply involved in
the work that's publishing it because
they they care about it yeah yeah
exactly
um and and what else maybe that's maybe
that's it we are supported by you we
appreciate you sharing and liking and
subscribing uh especially on Rumble
actually you know subscribing on Rumble
which is totally free um helps us out a
lot joining us on locals which you can
do free or paid helps us out as well and
uh and we we appreciate it very much
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well
[Music]
everybody